[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANTHONY HYLICK:
Welcome to Cloud OnAir
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Anthony
Hylick, and today I
will be talking
about extensible AI
with H2O, Google Cloud
Platform, and Kubeflow.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform,
and we have Google is on
standby to answer them.
Let's get started.
So today we'll be talking
about extensible AI,
and I'll be presenting this
first portion with Nick Png.
So we wanted to make distributed
portable machine learning
on Kubernetes easy for people
to deploy, develop, and manage
those installations.
And this is something we set
out as the mission for Kubeflow.
With containers and
container deployments,
we had a similar problem
that we overcame in 2014
when we developed Kubernetes.
We wanted to
standardize the API so
that people could
develop and manage
these deployments much simpler.
However, even as easy as
Kubernetes makes container
deployments, installing
machine learning on Kubernetes
isn't that easy.
You would first have
to become an expert
in all of these
areas-- containers,
packaging, persistent volume,
scaling, GPUs, cloud APIs, et
cetera.
Enter Kubeflow.
Kubeflow was developed
to make this easier,
so that everyone-- yes,
everyone-- could develop
distributed portable
machine learning
on containers and Kubernetes.
So a deployment like this,
where you had a workflow
lifecycle on the left
side and these clusters
on the right side,
then becomes replaced
by a Kubernetes installation
and abstraction of Kubeflow,
and then you're able to do
development on your laptop
locally.
You're able to train on
your on-prem cluster,
and you can also
deploy in the Cloud.
So with that, I will hand
it over to Vinod and Nick
to give us an
introduction to H2O.ai,
and what they've
done with Kubeflow.
VINOD IYENGAR: Who's H2O.ai?
We are a Silicon
Valley funded company.
We've been in existence
for about six years
now, born in 2012.
Our investors are Wells Fargo,
Nvidia, and Nexus, and Paxion.
We are a team of
about 90 experts,
including five of the world's
top grandmasters and data
scientists.
We have multiple products-- most
folks know us by our H2O open
source machine
learning platform,
which is used by over
14,000 organizations--
and H2O.ai, which is our
automated machine learning
platform.
We are headquartered in Mountain
View right across the street,
and we have a global presence,
including London, Prague,
and India.
Most recently, H2O was named
as a leader in the 2018 Gartner
Data Science and Magic Machine
Learning Magic Quadrant.
We were named as a
leader with the most
completeness of vision.
We were also recognized
for our quasi industry
standard and the mindshare among
machine learning platforms.
A lot of the machine
learning frameworks you see
do use H2O open
source under the hood.
H2O Customers also gave us
the highest overall score
amongst all vendors for
sales, success, and support.
In the H2O product suite,
we have multiple lines.
We have the H2O open source
also known as H2O Core.
That's the in-memory,
distributed machine learning
platform.
We have Sparkling
Water, which is
H2O running on top
of Apache Spark;
and H2O4GPU, which is basically
our machine learning algorithm
ported over to run on GPUs.
They are all 100% open source
in the Apache v2 license,
built for data scientists.
We have interfaces
in R and Python,
really easy to
pick up and learn;
and H2O Flow, which is our
interactive notebook interface.
We offer enterprise support
for those softwares.
On the right, you see our
commercial enterprise offering
called as Driverless
AI, where we essentially
do automatical
features using machine
learning interpretability.
It's a commercial
license software.
It's built for domain users,
analysts, data scientists,
and business users.
It has a full
GUI-based interface
for end-to-end machine
learning and data science.
So let's talk about H2O-3
first, our open source platform.
What is H2O?
So H2O is essentially
a math platform,
which provides basically an
open source and memory AI
engine that provides a
whole bunch of parallelized
and distributed algorithms--
popular ones like GLM, Random
Forest, GBM, Deep Learning,
et cetera.
It's also an API
written in Java,
so that programmers can
take advantage of it
inside their applications.
It's a very lightweight install.
It can work on any environment,
where basic Java environment
can support it.
It is built for big data.
You can build lots
of models with it,
and you can use as much data
as you have without sampling.
So the algorithms in H2O, if you
take a look at it for a second,
we covered the most
commonly used machine
learning algorithms, including
statistical algorithms
like linear models,
naive Bayes--
an ensemble treatment--
there's, like,
Random Forest, Gradient
Boosting Machines,
and we also have a bunch of
Stacking and Super Learning
algorithms built in.
We also support deep learning
deep neural networks,
including autoencoders, people
on neural networks, et cetera.
On the right, you see a bunch
of unsupervised learning
algorithms, including
clustering methods like K-means.
We also support dimensionality
reduction techniques like PCA
and generalized low rank models.
We also have NLP supported
through Word2Vec and time
series algorithm called ISax.
In addition, all
of our algorithms
do have a wide variety of
hyper parameters to tune for.
We offer early stopping
and AutoML functionality,
so that you can tune through
all the different algorithms
and get an ensemble
of the best models.
So if you take a
look, for a minute,
at the typical enterprise
machine learning workflow,
you have data simply
sitting in different silos.
They are all being
brought together,
and after you perform some
kind of detailed operation,
the data quality and
transformation techniques
are then applied on it.
And then you have,
what you call,
a modeling ready
data frame, where
you do feature engineering--
which can often
mean transformation
of existing features
into better features
that are more adaptable for
machine learning algorithms.
And after that,
you then typically
spend time doing machine
learning and trying
out different algorithms, and
you have final model artifact.
So how does H2O fit
into this workflow?
So with H2O, you can ingest
data from a wide variety
of data sources, including most
common on-prem and Cloud data
sources.
So if you have data sitting in
HTFS or Google Cloud Storage,
for example, or
any other database,
you can pull data into different
connectors that we support.
Once data is brought
into H2O, then it's
basically converted into
a distributed key value
store that's attached
to a data frame.
Once data is in there, you
can apply a whole bunch
of exploratory techniques,
feature engineering and model
building algorithms,
all of which
are fully parallelized
and distributed.
And that's the sum
of the platform.
For the user, they can
use this through the REST
API, which in turn lets you
use R, or Python, or H2O Flow.
Or if you're a programmer,
you can directly
work from Java or Scala.
But for the end user, it's all
fully abstracted in [? DC ?]
and single H2O frame, where
they can operate on and apply
all these different techniques.
Once you run through all
the different models,
then you can essentially
export the model as a POJO
or as a MOJO, which are
basically Java artifacts that
encapsulate an entire model.
And these artifacts are
ready to go into production.
You can deploy them into
a streaming environment.
Put them in, like, a
serverless architecture--
Lambda architecture
if you want--
or you can take the code and
embed into any application
that you might have.
So how does that fit into
the Kubeflow paradigm?
So typically, in H2O,
you might spin up
a bunch of machines--
bare metal machines--
and create an H2O cluster,
where you run the H2O models.
Instead of doing
that, if you were
to use Kubeflow as
an abstraction layer
above the bare
metal and the H2O--
what that lets you
do is essentially
a team of data
scientists can all
share the same Kubeflow and
Kubernetes cluster to create
multiple H2O clusters.
And these clusters can all
be running in parallel,
so multiple data scientists
can spin up a H2O cluster,
do their job, submit
their workloads,
and then turn it off,
and keep doing that.
It also allows you to
scale up if you want to.
For example, if your
workloads increase
you can have more nodes added
to the underlying Kubernetes
or Kubeflow cluster.
This can obviously run on
top of Cloud or on-prem.
Now let's get to
Driverless AI, which
is our commercial
enterprise software.
What does Driverless AI do?
Driverless AI delivers an
expert data scientist in a box.
What we did is we created
an expert AI system, which
was built by the world's
most top Kaggle masters
and AI experts, and the goal
was to empower companies
to accomplish end-to-end
machine learning and data
science with a single platform.
It performs the work of a data
scientist in the sense that it
does all the feature engineering
and model-building activities
that an expert data
scientist would perform
and gives you a really
highly accurate model which
is ready to go to production.
We also use a lot of different
visualization techniques
and interpretability
techniques to help understand
the results that are
created from the model,
so that you can build
trust in your model.
So if you will take a look
at the typical enterprise
machine learning workflow
that we saw earlier,
what Driverless AI does
now is it automates
the entire workflow
from the point when
you had the data frame ready.
So the feature engineering,
model building, deployment,
and interpretability,
they're all
taken care of by Driverless AI.
So from data ingested
to production,
we automated the
entire workflow.
And this is, of course,
our marketing software
which won the InfoWorld
Technology of the Year Award.
So why is Driverless AI a game
changer for enterprises, right?
So if you think about the three
common problems for enterprise
AI option, it's the
lack of AI talent.
There's a serious trade
of experienced expert data
scientists.
It takes a lot of time
for data scientists,
even the ones who are
trained and experienced,
to build models.
It can take anywhere from weeks
to days to build these models,
and the models they build are
often black box models which
are really tough to interpret.
So businesses have a tough
time trusting these models
in production.
So what do we do with
Driverless AI is essentially
solve all these three problems
by offering a digital data
scientist-- essentially a
data scientist in a box.
We automate the entire
machine learning workflow,
using GPU accelerated
machine learning,
so that the time to build a
model goes from weeks to hours.
So we are drastically
reducing the time taken.
And finally, we do
offer explanations
and interpretations
for all the models
that we build in Driverless
AI, so that helps
build trust and transparency.
So you can put these molds into
production knowing how and why
a prediction was being made.
So when we look at Driverless
AI, how well do we perform?
We took Driverless AI to task
by letting it participate
in some of these
Kaggle competitions,
and what we found is
that out of the box,
the Driverless AI comes
in the top five percentile
in most competitions.
And in some
competitions, it does
come in the top one percentile.
And if you look at the people
who beat Driverless AI,
all the data scientist experts
took days and weeks of work,
whereas Driverless AI was
able to match the performance
in a matter of hours.
So it provides this
automatic feature engineering
model building to give you the
most accuracy for your models.
So what kind of
feature engineering
do we perform, right?
Very quickly, if
you look at it--
I know Nick is going to cover
that in a demo in a little bit,
but essentially we
are doing things
like automatic text
handling, frequency encoding,
cross-validated target encoding,
truncated SVD, clustering.
These are things
that experienced
and expert data
scientists would do time
and again to help improve
the accuracy of their models.
You apply the
feature engineering,
then do model building, and
then see which features came out
as significant.
And you do this
iteratively, and that's
what Driverless AI automates.
It goes through this
entire process iteratively
and gives you the power of an
experienced data scientist.
And finally, let's talk a
minute about the deployment.
Whether it be H2O-3
or Driverless AI,
we always offer full
deployment options.
Every model built in either
in H2O or Driverless AI
comes with the JAVA artifact.
It's either a POJO
or MOJO file that's
ready to go into production.
These artifacts are built for
a low latency inferencing,
so we are able to do some
millisecond inferencing.
And these models
can then be deployed
into different environments.
They can be put on
the cloud or on-prem.
Put it behind a
REST API service,
so your applications can
take advantage of it.
So we go from the entire
lifecycle model training
management and deployment.
And that's a wrap at this point.
Over to you, Nick.
NICHOLAS PNG: Here's a quick
demo on some of the products
that we have
running on Kubeflow.
So as you can see on
the left hand side,
we have just a quick repo.
This is the work that we've been
doing between Google's Kubeflow
team as well as H2O.
And on the right hand side,
we have a terminal window
that's open to our
Kubernetes master
instance, which is connected to
a couple of Kubernetes slaves.
So if you take a look here,
I can do kubectl get nodes,
and it will tell me that I
have the master as well as
two slaves connected and ready.
And if you do kubectl
describe nodes,
you can see just exactly
what is available on each.
So you have the
amount of memory,
you have the number of max pods
available as a number of CPUs
per node, and you can see that
there are three nodes attached.
So the first thing that
we're going to run through
is just a quick demo
of Driverless AI, which
is our enterprise platform.
So if you take a look
here, ks component--
or sorry, list ls components--
you can see that there is a
couple of different components
here.
The first one is Driverless,
and that's the component
that we're going to deploy.
Now, because Driverless AI
is an enterprise platform,
I have pre-deployed it, so
that I can add a license,
and we can use it.
So if we do kubectl get pods,
you can actually take a look
and see that Driverless
AI is running right here.
So the first thing that
we're going to do is--
so since its pre-deployed, I
already have it right here.
Basically, this is
driverless AI and the GUI
that comes associated with it.
There are a couple of different
methods to ingest data.
Google Cloud Storage
and Big Query
have pre-built connectors.
And if we use Google
Cloud Storage,
we can actually just go
straight to our public demo data
and import the data
set that we want.
So the dataset
that's being imported
is called credit card train--
it's basically a data set for a
credit card company from China,
and the target that
we're predicting
is default next month.
So it's a
classification problem.
If we click Predict
from here, you
can go to the experiment
GUI, which is right here.
So if you were to
click Experiments,
this is what you would get
after selecting a data set.
And we want to select the Target
column as Default Payment.
Now, we do have a
couple tuning knobs
to tune for accuracy,
time, and interpretability.
And if we just hit Go,
it'll start the experiment.
From here, you can actually see
that the experiment is running.
And while this is
going on, we'll
go ahead and take a look at
the other parts of our demo.
And if I take a look at the
actual components within it,
you can see components
here-- environments,
which is just a
namespace area where
you can have different locations
of where the deployments are.
So you could have,
say, an environment
for Cloud or on-prem.
The components are
the important part.
The components, if
you ls components,
is going to show you all the
different components that
are available to us right now.
So I have Driverless
AI, which is
available as a
driverless.json component.
And I have H2O Static,
which is the H2O-3
cluster available as
another component as well.
These are made available
through the repo.
So if you take a look
here under H2O Kubeflow,
you can see there's the
Driverless package H2O
scaling, which is a prototype,
and H2O Static, which
is the standard
cluster that we have.
And if I do ks pkg
list, we can actually
see these are the
available packages that
have been added here.
If you have seen
the Kubeflow repo--
it's github.com/kubeflow,
I believe--
you can actually see that the
best way to import or install
a package would
be ks pkg install,
and then the
registry name, which
is just the file name right
here, H2O Kubeflow slash--
since I already have the
other ones installed,
I'll just install H2O-3-scaling.
So as you can see,
it's installed.
And if I do ks pkg
list again, you
can see that now there's another
asterisk basically saying
that it's been installed.
Now, I've pre-baked a couple
of the components, which is why
you're able to see them here.
But if I were to use
ks prototype type use
io.ksonnet.pkg.h2o3-static--
and we'll rename this something
else, H2O-3 demo slash--
and then add the
necessary parameters--
namespace, we'll just
call this Default.
And then here is where you
want to add some parameters.
So how much memory
do you want to give
the cluster-- or rather--
each node in the cluster?
How many CPUs do you want to
give each node in the cluster?
Since this is a toy
component-- since I already
have the other one
pre-baked-- we'll
just give it one gig of memory.
This is not
recommended, by the way.
CPU-- just give it one CPU.
And number of replicas--
so a number of replicas
being the number of nodes that
you want in the H2O-3 cluster.
So we can name this 4.
It doesn't really matter
for this specific component.
The important thing is
the model server image,
and this one is going
to be just the repo--
the Docker Hub repo
under which you've stored
the Docker image that
is going to be deployed.
So in this case, you can
actually look back in the repo.
It does exist-- Docker files--
and any of the Docker
files are available
here for you to build and host
on one of the Docker Hub--
on your Docker Hub repo or
another location locally--
H2O-3 Kubeflow.
Typos do exist--
model server image.
There we go.
And basically what that does
is it creates a component.
So now if I go ls
components again,
you'll see that now there
is a H2O-3 demo, as well
as Driverless, as
well as H2O-3 Static.
Now, I did pre-deploy
a Driverless AI,
because it is a
licensed product,
so we wanted to make
sure to be able to show
the product without the
license, you know, being shown.
So if I do kubectl
get pods, you'll
actually see that Driverless
AI is actually already running
and is already existing.
And if I do kubectl
describe pod Driverless AI,
you can actually see
we have allocated
a certain amount of memory--
no GPUs for this just
because the slaves
did not have GPUs to start with.
But our Driverless AI
is optimized for GPUs
and actually runs about
5x faster, so definitely
recommended to use GPUs.
So this is the
Driverless AI GUI.
So this is what you get when
you attach to the Kubernetes
instance through Kubeflow.
Now, you can ingest data through
a couple of different ways.
There's built-in connectors
to Google Cloud Storage
as well as Google BigQuery.
We'll use Google
Cloud Storage for now.
H2O GCS public data--
demo data.
gs, H2O, gcs public demo data--
this should work.
Let's just try and
refresh it here.
I believe there is
some networking--
H2O GCS.
There, we go-- demo data.
There, we go.
So I'm just going to import--
this is a basic data
set that we use.
It's called the
credit card data set.
Basically, it has
credit card data
to predict whether
or not you're going
to default in the next month.
And while I run through
the rest of the demos,
I'm going to actually run
this in the background,
so that we can get an idea of
what it looks like at the end.
So basically, all you have
to do is click Predict
and basically select
which column you
want to do the prediction on.
If you have a validation
data set, which we do,
we can add that.
Toggle which score you
want-- as well as some tuners
as to how long you want
it to take, how accurate--
or rather what weight
you have for accuracy as
compared to interpretability--
and click Run.
While this is
running, I'm actually
going to go through the
quick deployment of H2O-3.
So if we take, again,
a look at components
we can see that there is the
H2O-3 Static jsonnet available.
And from here, the
package is easy, right?
If we components.params, you
can actually take a look.
We have all the parameters
set up, pre-baked.
So once you have a
component set up,
you actually can just
deploy this wherever
and however you want
in whatever namespace
you want in
whichever environment
you want available
through redirecting
the connection to kubectl.
So you can configure
kubectl to connect
to your on-prem resources,
run a couple experiments,
then connect to the
Cloud in GCE or GCP
to run your on-Cloud
experiments as well.
So from here, all we have to
do is-- because the component
is already set up
here, ks apply default,
minus c for the
component that we want,
and we'll go H2O-3 Static.
Now, it takes just a
second, which you can see
is-- it's actually creating a
service, which is pre-defined,
as well as the deployments
necessary to run
H2O-3 and create the cluster.
Now, this one had a
cluster of three set up
with two CPUs per
node as well as
six gigabytes memory per node.
Now, it's generally
recommended that you
have about 4x amount of
memory for the amount of data
that you want.
So if you're using
a gig of data,
then you probably want about
4 gigs memory available
so that the H2O-3 cluster can do
all the things it needs to do.
And now if we take a
look-- kubectl get pods--
again, you'll see that now there
are a couple deployments here.
And it looks like we're
having demo bugs--
or not.
kubectl get pods, there we go.
False alarm, it seems like.
So now if we look at
the services-- get svc--
you can actually take a look.
And we have an
available node balancer
that is forwarding the
port that we expose, 54321,
to another available port
that we can then connect to.
So if we then attach to
the Kubernetes master
here and then add the
port that we need,
we can see-- now this
is basically H2O Flow.
It's one of the options
for running H2O--
as well as you can
run either through R
or through Python interpreters.
Basically, this gives us a much
more point-and-click method
of ingesting data as well
as performing machine
learning practice-- or
machine learning experiments.
The difference being is that
you can just click Import Files,
or click Get Frames,
or click Predict,
and it will actually do--
it will give you--
the code is all self-baked.
And all you really have to do is
just add some small parameters
rather than writing
in R or Python,
so you don't necessarily
need to know those languages.
Now, if you were
interested in using Python,
then there is the Python Client.
And I've pre-spawned
a Jupyter notebook.
Basically, all you have
to do is import H2O,
so this has to be
installed locally.
And from H2O, you can do--
from H2O.out.
I'll import H2O AutoML.
And this is just one of the
packages AutoML is basically
a package that will run
a very in-depth grid
search across multiple
different algorithms
in order to find the ones
that are most effective,
essentially, across your data.
So from here, now that we've
actually imported H2O--
and you can actually take
a look through H2O Flow
here if I do admin and
get cluster status.
You can see that there's
actually three nodes attached,
and you can see some
available memory,
which is the amount of memory
that I've allocated previously.
And we'll actually see this
once I connect here as well.
So h2o.init port is equal to--
and I'm just going to have to
copy, paste the port again,
or rather the IP and the port,
which is this one right here.
Oh, there we go.
So basically, this is pre-baked.
It's just called the cluster,
but this can be renamed.
As you can see, again, 3 nodes--
the total free
memory, which should
aggregate to close to 18.
But there is a small
drop off because you
want to not use the maximum
heap memory for H2O-3
because it's written in Java.
So Java actually takes away
about 10% for itself to run.
So at this point,
you're connected.
And you can do
basically the same thing
as you could do in H2O Flow
but just with the Python
interpreter.
So you can do train is
equal to H2O.ImportFile,
which would be able
to get you your data
if you pass it from GCS.
There is a GCS connector.
Now, this is an
open source product,
so the GCS connector
is actually built
by an external party,
from what I have heard,
and is getting merged soon.
But, you know, there's
also s3 connectors,
as well as from local
source, and most
anywhere as long as it's
openly available for H2O
to connect and grab.
At the moment, unfortunately,
there was a minor bug
that we were dealing
with previous to this
just this morning, so I haven't
been able to import any data.
But we can take
a quick look back
at our experiment, which
should have finished already.
Validation set is missing.
So it seems the
validation set that's here
doesn't have the necessary
column, so we're actually
just going to have to rerun.
Or we can rerun the
experiment, but we
can go and describe
this really quick
while we're going through it.
Just a quick understanding--
a little bit more about what's
going on here is that there's
a couple of tuning knobs--
basically, accuracy,
which is how highly do you
want to rate accuracy?
So 10 would be the highest.
One would be the least.
And the model
itself will actually
be built based on this.
So if you set a
low accuracy, it's
going to prioritize
running quicker.
It's going to prioritize
making a more simple model.
Time is also somewhat
dependent on the other,
but basically meaning if
you allow it 10 for time,
it means you don't mind
it running forever--
or not forever but for
a much longer time--
and then you're probably likely
preferring more complex models
and higher accuracy.
So that's what Driverless
AI will prioritize.
And finally, there's
interpretability.
Interpretability is essentially
the difference between, say,
having a stacked ensemble model
of 10 XGBoost models or maybe
one-- or the idea being the
difference between having
a neural net or a
linear regression--
so linear regressions obviously
being more interpretable.
So that would be if your
interpretability was 10--
versus one might be
something more complicated--
a neural net or a
stacked ensemble
of several XGBoost models.
So you can actually see
what's going on here.
So right now we have a couple
different charts, but basically
this just shows, you know,
how much lift you're gaining--
your precision versus
a recall because this
is a classification--
of your rock curve.
And this is across
the number of epochs--
just the performance that
the machine is outputting
against your validation data.
So because our validation
data set was missing a column,
it's actually going to just
do cross-validation splits.
So you're basically taking a
section out of the training
data set and running
on each iteration that
has the validation score.
So that's what
we're seeing here.
It's not just
taking the data set
and training itself
on it over and over.
So what's really cool here
is the variable importance,
and this is something that
Vinod highlighted earlier.
Essentially, what it is is
that you can see a couple
columns, which are like Pay 1.
This is actually a column that
exists in the normal data set,
but there's also other
data sets like CVTE Pay 1,
which is the cross-validated
target encoding for that
specific column--
which I believe that's
actually Pay 10.
Excuse me.
So that's the cross-validated
target encoding
of the column Pay 10.
So the difference is is
that one was actually
generated by the model and
by Driverless AI itself--
versus Pay 1, which was
something that just came along
with the data set.
And since this is a
very small data set,
it seems trained fairly quickly.
And once it completes,
it will actually
train a final model that can
be output as a MOJO or POJO.
So we can actually wait for
that to go since it's going
to finish in just a second.
And the last thing is--
after this is trained--
you can actually run MLI.
MLI stands for Machine
Learning Interpretability.
And what it does is it basically
takes you or more complex model
if you were to, say,
have an accuracy of 10
and an interpretability
of 1, you
can actually take
that model afterwards,
and it will run several--
the equivalent of,
like, several linear
regressions to match what the
more complex XGBoost model is
doing under the hood.
So that you can actually
see what's going on--
see the reasoning
and the decision
making behind our
more complex model.
For, in many cases,
like certain verticals
like the financial vertical,
this would be very important.
So from here you can actually
see-- so this would be MLI.
If you clicked
Interpret this Model,
it'll actually start
interpreting it.
I can actually close
that while it's running,
so MLI is running right now.
And we can actually just
go back to the experiment
and take a look.
So this is where you might
want to download an experiment
summary, download some logs--
if you build the
MOJO scoring pipeline
in this or the Python scoring
pipeline, which would be POJO,
this is where you would
get the deployment that you
would be able to deploy.
Quite probably the best
place would be in the Cloud
or on Kubernetes where
it's scalable to demand,
and you could use it
to make predictions.
So it looks like we're running
out of time, so I think--
stay tuned for a live Q&A. We'll
be back in less than a minute.
And welcome back with our
Q&A. So the first question
is, what machine learning
platforms can run on Kubeflow,
and is it limited to TensorFlow?
The answer is no.
It's not limited to TensorFlow.
In fact, I believe
in the Kubeflow repo
there's several different
packages already
there as well, inclusive
Caffe, Karas, I believe,
as well as TensorFlow for deep
learning with machine learning.
This is what H2O does, and we're
running on Kubeflow right now.
So that's probably, I would say,
there's a lot of opportunities
right here.
H2O has been leveraging
it for the better
of a couple of months since
we started the partnership,
and it seems to run fairly well.
So yeah, H2O-3 as another
option for machine
learning on Kubeflow.
ANTHONY HYLICK: So
the next question
is can I run Kubeflow on-prem?
Absolutely, that was
part of the design
around something
that was portable
and for distributed
machine learning.
You could run it on-prem.
You could run it on your
laptop via mini cube.
You can run it in the Cloud.
Anywhere you have
Kubernetes, the goal
is to be able to run Kubeflow.
The next question
we have is-- what
is the security privacy
compliance for Kubeflow
running on the cloud?
Is this any different
than running a VM?
There are no additional
security or privacy concerns
that Kubeflow opens up.
So any of the same container
or VM concerns that you have,
these are going to
maintain-- those concerns are
going to stay the same
when you use Kubeflow.
And the last
question we have is--
can I use you GPU/TPU with
Kubeflow running on GCP?
Absolutely, you
can use both GPUs
or you can use TPUs, whichever
you need for the work
that you need to get
done, or the performance,
or the accuracy
that you're after.
GPUs and TPUs are
available for those cases.
NICHOLAS PNG: Actually, if
I could elaborate once more
on question number two.
So running on-prem
for with Kubeflow--
one of the things that we
are currently working on--
a prototype, if you will--
with the Kubeflow
team is actually
the opportunity to
do burst to cloud,
which would mean that
you start on-prem
with, say, four machines, or
three machines, or however
many.
And if your demand does
exceed the amount of resources
available on-prem, then you can
actually just spin up another
machine that will be on GCP--
so through GCE.
And it will attach itself
to the Kubernetes cluster
and then act as a new resource
for the Kubernetes cluster.
And then basically it'd
be a first-class citizen
for being spun down,
ultimately, once the resources
load is reduced.
So that's actually
something we're working on.
We actually have
a couple scripts
that are on the H2O
Kubeflow repo that
are kind of the
prototypes of this,
and they will continue to be
updated as time progresses.
ANTHONY HYLICK: Yeah,
absolutely, burst to cloud
enables dynamic
capacity increase
and decrease as your
workload needs it.
NICHOLAS PNG: Yeah.
ANTHONY HYLICK: So
that's it for Q&A.
I guess, stay tuned
for the next session,
99 Problems but GPU Ain't One.
[MUSIC PLAYING]